you still having fun out there am I
still heavy that is a Lukas if I'm still
having fun I think you are definitely
enjoying yourself I'm still having fun
yeah yeah you know looking at what
you've kind of created here if there was
figuring it out do you feel like you
have it figured out that's a good
interesting question I figured out what
I do yeah I think your gift has to be
knowing what you can do or knowing what
you can't do and I know that there are
many many things that I can't do this is
something that I can do and I've been
doing it in one form or another for 50
years
luring and judging and in one venue or
another so do I think I have it figured
out I do when they first approached you
about doing a television show always
your initial reaction I my initial
reaction was I could do that my initial
reaction was I could do that but I also
knew that most of what was produced
failed it didn't find an audience it
didn't wasn't didn't have the right
exposure the audience didn't embrace the
personality what many reasons so and I
was giving up I was giving up a good
civil service job that I liked being a
judge in New York but I thought it was
going to be better for it to be a new
adventure for me a different adventure
life is you only have one shot at it
it's supposed to be an interesting
journey are you why do you think the
show's been so successful when you
mentioned that are you playing an
archetype like did you did you did you
say hey this is a persona I want to put
forth that I think people will gravitate
to or is this who you were before as
well no I'm really not a great actress
the one of the few times that I had to
learn lines was many years ago when I
was doing Saturday Night Live and I
maybe had three lines and it was the
most stressful thing that I ever did
they and they had it on cue cards I said
what happens if the guy with the cue
cards messes up what happens if he puts
one in front I couldn't do it it just
wasn't my thing so fortunately I don't
have to prepare to come to work for me I
think the reason that the show
translates as it does not only in this
country but in other countries is
because people are really the same the
same irritations you saw a case that we
did today involving a couple that were
no longer a couple and the young woman
was a lovely young woman and her feeling
of disappointment and and sadness at the
end of the relationship which turned
into a violent outburst which caused a
little damage to his car who cares that
same feeling exists where they live in
Illinois or Quebec or Montreal or Texas
it's the same feeling and so I think
that
for me I don't have to prepare to come
to work anymore I know my business you
still feel nervous when you go to work
little bit older today a little nervous
today that's okay nervous today
when I do something new or something
that's out of my comfort zone when I
have to give a commencement address and
it has to be it's not a QA like this so
it has to be has to be solid and has to
be cohesive and if you lose a thread and
you go out on a tributary you have to
come back otherwise the audience is
scratching their head and said what's
happening with her
so that's stressful but this isn't
stressful for me anymore
you mentioned relationships you're
successful in the Quorum as you are
outside of the courtroom
you know you've been married for four
years what do you tribute that kind of
success too
being a good sport and having a sense of
humor it's a good way to look at it it's
interesting because you're adored you
know pretty much around the world and
you know bird said but people see you in
a certain light and bird was saying that
you know outside of the courtroom
there's a very sensitive side and
there's a softy I'm gonna have to figure
out where he saw the sensitive side
what who's most likely to bring that out
in you I would imagine to be your
grandkids no my dog whose true travels
with me what's your dog's name
my dog scout scout scout little little
thing well I think it was grandchildren
when they were younger yeah and you know
that now they know most of the
grandchildren were older and a result
you know grown all grown up so is it a
soft side I don't know whether I would
actually say it's a softer side I get
down on the floor and play with the
puppy
I wouldn't and play back grandkids
anymore
I just I just wouldn't